Welcome back everyone this will be my full video
for the boys season 3 episode 8 it's the finale
there's a whole bunch of easter eggs obviously
we're getting season four but if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet we'll just start at the
beginning and work our way through shot by shot
talking about easter eggs wtf moments as we go
along and i will do a video for season four this
weekend too because we do know a little bit about
what their plans are for season four there are a
couple really big story lines that they tease at
the end of the episode too so you kind of have an
idea for what's going on but the episode title is
the instant white hot wild which is a reference
to the comic book issue number 38 now the comic
book plot is vastly divergent from the tv show
plot but thematically there are some similarities
like most of the titles of boyz episodes are taken
from the titles of comic book chapters but the
events of the chapters with the same name don't
correspond to the actual plot of the episodes the
title instant white hot wild is also a metaphor
for soldier boy's power in the flashbang
metaphorical ending fight where he blows up
but may protects everyone by taking him out the
window there's some similarities in ryan's story
arc during this episode the whole idea of fathers
and sons in kimico during that issue 38 that the
title takes its inspiration from when kimiko chose
a different path like she was raised or handled by
these people who just forced her to do all these
terrible things and eventually she chose her own
path they kind of want to tie that to ryan's
storyline because he's obviously a much bigger
character heading into season four like the whole
idea now is what is ryan going to do is he going
to drink the kool-aid and become just as terrible
as homelander or is he going to choose his own
path and choose something better the actual
opening scene is ryan playing this really sad game
of catch with himself just throwing the ball super
far because of his powers and then confirming that
home later got his address from victoria newman
and even though there's this whole storyline
they've had all these seasons of the boys wanting
to kill homelander him being a complete psychopath
the way they play this scene though is meant to
be like this genuine emotion from homeland like he
genuinely cares about ryan wants to have a family
with him even though he's also a psychopath on
the side he really is just like this hurt little
boy that just wants a family that's all he cares
about like he doesn't actually care about being a
superhero he just wants love from other people and
i love the creepy way that they play this too like
ryan himself they also reveal has blamed himself
for the death of becca this whole time he's been
living with all that guilt and the main reason why
he's been so afraid of homelander is because he
felt like homelander hated him for killing becca
so when homelander tries to wipe all that guilt
away like don't blame yourself accidents happen
that's why he runs to him in his very luke
skywalker darth vader kind of scene like what
would have happened if luke skywalker had actually
learned darth vader was his father when he was a
little kid obi-wan kenobi basically talks about
this during return of the jedi like the reason why
we held that truth from you is because you would
have run straight to him and we would have lost
you a version of that basically happens during
the episode like at the end of the episode you see
ryan just get twisted a little bit evil learning
all the wrong lessons from what homelander does
with the crowd that are killing that person in the
crowd celebrating him for it and i love the downer
way that they play this moment like it's meant to
be a hopeful moment like oh yeah you know both of
them are getting the family that they never had
before they've always wanted but they had that
really creepy music cue because of everything
that happens later in the episode like wait a
minute homelanders is a psychopath he's doing
all these terrible things ryan kind of seems
like he's also going to go full bright burn and
do all these terrible things during season four
then they start setting up all these protests that
are going on between starlight supporters and all
of homelanders and the seven supporters really
it's homelander but it's kind of like everything
that vaud is telling them because homeland is
a representative of vought like he's kind of
in charge of the company now in the way they're
playing this is meant to turn into this real world
allegory for all the culture war stuff that's
been happening the past couple of years because
next season we're like literally heading into that
presidential election that they just teased at the
end of the episode and we basically been living
through a version of that the last couple of years
in the real world i think a really easy way
to think about it is the spiderman no way home
mysterio video so in spiderman no way home they
reveal the consequences of mysterio's video
the way they play it is that basically like half
of the population believes mysterio's lies and
the other half doesn't believe them that's kind
of been going on with janine's stepdad like he
literally is the person who starts cheering for
homeland or the minute that he kills the dude
that disrespects ryan you have to imagine that
kind of movement that happens there and that
crowd spreading as we head into the presidential
election in season four like it's only gonna get
worse it's kind of like the ultimate fulfillment
of the end of season two where homelander goes
even crazier and is on top of the building just
totally doing it to himself saying i can do
anything i want in actually believing it even at
the end of the episode too when homelander sees
the crowd cheering for him like oh wait a minute
i just killed that dude are they gonna hate me now
no wait they love me oh my god they love me this
is amazing he is legit surprised at the crowd's
reaction because if you remember during season
two he had a hallucination where he thought that
he might actually open up on that entire crowd
killing them all and he was so worried that
people would stop loving him because of that but
now they've basically shown that people will love
him almost no matter what or at least a certain
portion of people will love him no matter what
just allowing him to become even crazier and
crazier in season four there's a lot of really
subtle ashley moments in this episode too the
first one being ashley actually looking at maeve
being genuinely sorry like trying to tell her i'm
so sorry about this and actually caring about what
happens to her if it wasn't clear they were trying
to move maeve and then harvest her eggs to sort of
fulfill homelanders threat to her like okay we're
probably gonna kill you off but we'll take your
eggs beforehand so i can have a super baby with
you so ashley genuinely actually does feel sorry
for what's going to happen like she actually
cares what happens to maeve that's why she's
also horrified when she finds out what homelander
has done to black noir killing him and then later
when she deletes the footage of maeve surviving
they're kind of setting the stage for ashley and
other people inside the seven like a train in the
deep to turn and help the boys although it is kind
of hard to say which direction the deep is going
to go because he'll just do anything that anybody
tells him to do the whole thing with mother's
milk being remorseful for his daughter seeing
him knock out the stepfather even though he's gone
full-blown crazy town team homelander is meant to
be a parallel for what happens with ryan and home
later at the end of the episode like the idea
of the father passing on their bad drama their
baggage to their kids like teaching the kids the
wrong lesson father's messing their kids up which
is meant to flow with soldier boy's storyline too
mother's milk was just worried that his daughter
seeing his act of violence was gonna mess her up
in the head which it obviously doesn't they
played in a more hopeful way but the opposite
of that happens to ryan so he is now totally
messed up in the head heading into season four
like oh people like it when i'm violent like
this love when black noir came back to the seven
like you have all those hallucinations with
the cartoon characters following him around
especially talking to him later in the episode too
they do want to show you that he and homelander
are bros like he does care about homeland or he's
helped him in the past like even stuff during the
flashbacks they did during the animated series
he tries to tell homelander the actual truth
but because he's not so articulate he's not able
to get the message across homelander is just so
desperate to have a family that he's willing to
overlook all the crazy stuff that's going on with
soldier boy the way they play their storyline too
like even though homelander kills him in a really
messed up wtf way like he's crying while
he's doing it he's sad to kill his friend
they played in the very captain america civil war
kind of way with iron man and captain america like
you should have told me dude the secret the
captain america was keeping from iron man was
bucky being the person to kill his parents but
obviously in the case of the boys it was black
noir knowing that soldier boy used the genetic
material to help create homelander but true to
his word black noir wasn't lying they should have
killed soldier boy right on the spot there wasn't
much of a frenchie storyline in the finale he just
has a couple funny moments and it's just about him
asserting himself and trying to leave behind his
trauma it was meant to be a very similar storyline
for a lot of the other characters like huey
kind of realizing what was going on and trying
to get past all of his trauma too not taking the
temporary compound v anymore realizing that he
didn't need it frenchie realizing that he didn't
need to try to run away from all of his problems
i love the story that huey told about his father
because we're talking about simon peg here he
plays his father on the tv show but if you've read
the boys comic book then the character of huey was
actually animated by the person who created the
comic book to look just like simon pegg and had
the comic book been adapted into a tv show in the
early 2000s it would have been simon pegg playing
huey but it just took so long that he aged out
of the role and now he's playing huey's father
but if you watched the animated series the boys
diabolical they did an animated episode that's
meant to be much more accurate to the comic book
version of the characters and huey is animated to
look like simon pegg and voiced by simon pegg in
that one particular episode soldier boy reveals
his true backstory to butcher who hasn't seen
all the propaganda films that vox created about
him but i think you all understood that everything
that vox says about the origin of superheroes is
meant to be false like they create all these fake
backstories but soulja boy did come from world war
ii era like the most twisted version of a captain
america origin story you can imagine but it's
meant to explain why he's so terrible why he has
some of this trauma ptsd that he can't deal with
in present day and obviously why things go off
the rails at the end especially at the end of the
episode when homelander tries to sort of bring him
into the fold like come on we could work together
the film that vap made about him in 1951 a
soldier boy story was released the same year
lost the oscar to an american in paris which was
also released in 1951. that would have been why
the korean war was happening i'm assuming soldier
boy fought during that too when he talks about
doing jane wyman in the coat closet at the oscars
that year she was a famous actress who starred in
a film that year called the blue veil he reveals
his true backstory is that he came from a wealthy
family but he was kind of like a nerdy well his
father abused him mistreated him didn't really
care about him at all so eventually he used his
father's contacts in the government to get himself
into the early vought trials he had a version
of the captain america origin story where they
dosed him up he became a superhero but because
everything about him was fake like vox created
all this fake backstory everything they showed
him doing was meant to be fake his father kind
of saw through that and said you cheated and still
didn't care about him so the idea is in present
day soldier boy has wanted to have a family of
his own this whole time so that he could try to
do better but he's just been unable to overcome
all that childhood trauma and that's why he has
the conflict with homelander at the end like why
he can't just accept homelander for who he is
and if it wasn't clear why he hates homelander
is because he kind of hates himself like he sees
himself literally in home later because he's his
child so he kind of looks like him a little bit or
he's meant to look kind of like him and just the
sight of him reminds him of all the trauma that
he visited and he just can't overcome that and
also seeing all the emotion on homelanders face
which is why he tells him that he's weak even
though physically he's supposed to be stronger
than soldier boy the whole storyline with butcher
is they do want to redeem him a little bit like
yes he did save huey by knocking him out in the
bathroom and leaving him so that he wouldn't take
more compound b but because he's now basically
the point of no return they just want to show that
there's nothing left to lose for the character but
now he's also lost ryan to homelander even though
he still wants to kill homeland or he also wants
to keep that promise to becca to protect ryan
so what they're doing with this character is
just showing you that yes he is still terrible
he'll continue to be terrible but there is still
a glimmer of hope inside him like he tells huey
literally you really are the spitting image of
my brother and he is so remorseful about what
happened with his brother that they want to show
you that huey could potentially be his ultimate
redemption if that's going to be possible
now the comic book version of butcher is a
little bit different i think they're going to
be a little bit more hopeful with the tv show
version of butcher's ending but we'll talk about
that in a couple seasons if we get to that point
later when the doctor is telling him that his
timeline is basically 12 months to 18 months
before he dies that's basically giving you a
timeline for the last season of the show like
the show will probably end as butcher reaches the
end of his timeline love the way that homelander
just completely rakes the rest of the seven over
the coals like you're all worthless i hate all
you you're the worst version of a family that
anybody could ever have i mentioned this earlier
with ashley's storyline they're just trying to
set up the idea that the rest of the seven here
will eventually turn on homelander and when i say
literally do anything he'll say when he whispers
into his ear what he's telling him to do is
kill the competition victoria newman for the
presidential running mate i've already explained
all the supernatural easter eggs too with robert
singer's character that's the name of one of the
creators in the supernatural tv show but the actor
jim beaver was also on supernatural and there are
a lot of other supernatural actors like jensen
ackles for instance that are on the boys tv show
including the show runner of the boys tv show he
was the creator of the supernatural tv show i also
believe jeffrey dean morgan from supernatural will
be on boy season 4. we'll see if they complete the
trifecta and bring jared padalecki on the show it
wouldn't truly be a supernatural universe if they
didn't bring jared patalecki on before the end of
the series i also loved the reaction on a train's
face when he found out about the deep's octopus
story like what the reason you see the deep eating
all that junk food later while he's watching the
broadcast of his ex-wife now promoting her
own version of a tell-all book like he just
did against the church is him just developing a
version of ptsd behavior from all the crazy stuff
that he's done like all the compromises that he's
made to try and suck up to homelander are finally
taking their toll mentally on him and he'll just
continue acting out in crazier and crazier ways
we kind of saw a version that was soldier boy with
his outburst not being able to deal with his ptsd
same thing with the deep storyline during season
four probably then when they have their big scene
of homelander and soldier boy at the vaude tower
they played in a very luke skywalker darth vader
type of scene again this time obviously with two
different characters because ryan was like the
luke skywalker in the original situation but in
this scenario it's more of a return of the jedi
situation on the death star where you have older
luke skywalker homelanders character appealing
to soldier boy darth vader's character and it'd
be like luke skywalker appealing to darth vader
if he rejected him like if darth vader did
not redeem himself during return of the jedi
i've already explained why soldier boy did all
this too like why he completely went off the rails
mostly just being unable to get over his own
childhood trauma in the abuse that he suffered
at his father's hands they had some really good
fight scenes here too all around but mostly this
is about them dealing with soldier boy even though
queen maeve is like i don't care about that i just
want to kill homelander don't need to help here
don't need any kind of team ups going on just
want to kill homelander it was cool to see that
messed up moment of butcher and homelander working
together briefly even though they just absolutely
absolutely hate each other and like i said they
want to show you that homelander really does
care about ryan despite all the terrible stuff
that he's doing which basically feeds into the
whole idea that ryan kind of rushes to his arms
and chooses him over butcher because he wants
a family desperately too just like homelander
wants a family one of my few surprises though is
because obviously this final fight takes place in
a broadcast room they have the big twist where
huey powers up starlight gives your extra boost
because he turns all the lights in the room up i
actually expected huey to turn all the broadcast
cameras on so that they would just broadcast
everything that they were doing to the rest of
the world and they would see what's really going
on with all the superheroes like oh homelander's
terrible soldier boy is terrible we shouldn't
believe in any of these superheroes anymore
but the way they play it that didn't happen like
it's still very half and half situation where
like half the population supports homelander in
half the population believe everything starlight
said and think that superheroes were terrible and
if it wasn't clear the reason why maeve is able
to injure homelander is because she's almost as
powerful as him not nearly as powerful but like
amongst the seven in the boys characters all the
super powered characters she's like the closest to
being as powerful as homelander the one exception
to that would be ryan's character because he's his
biological son and they just want to tease how
potentially he could be just as powerful as him
i'll talk about that in a second too because i
think they're giving ryan a very big part of the
comic book plot with the boys going after homeland
or ultimately like the end game for homelander
will be homelander versus ryan superboy versus
superman that's why they have ryan wearing the
superboy colors but if it wasn't clear all the
damage that homelanders suffered during the
episode because he still has compound v powers all
healed by the end of the episode the reason why
maeve's injuries don't heal is because soldier
boy's power goes off before she fully heals
and so she loses all of her compound v powers but
if it wasn't clear the rest of the world thinks
that she's dead including homelander which is
the reason why she says she's taking off at the
end to hide from home later because if she lives
in the city homelanders super hearing would be
able to detect her and find her instantly she'll
be back during season four and season five like
however long the boys goes don't worry it's just
that she won't have her super powers unless she
takes more compound fee and it sounds like she
won't the song they have playing at the end was
elton john's goodbye yellow brick bro it's just
meant to be a metaphor for all the things going
to hell for all the characters like good times
are over because it's just getting worse and
worse and worse heading into season four season
five whatever the final season winds up being
they confirmed they're also keeping soldier boys
sedated in a very similar situation that the
russians were doing like they're effectively
keeping him in prison by keeping him gassed
up in this chamber but he's meant to be so strong
that's why he's not dead like they can't kill him
starlight quits the seven that's why she throws
her old starlight costume away and the reason
why butcher shows up drinking from the homelander
cup is just to remind you that he is the ultimate
goal like they still trying to kill homelander
in next season but then they confirmed the
theory that homelander was doing the solid paying
back victoria newman helping her become the vp
by killing her competition and now she's made
the list like butcher put her on the list okay
we're gonna kill her too now she is based on
a comic book character victoria newman is vic
the vp in the comics but he's called vic the vp
because he's the vp of the united states and he
used to be one of the ceos of vaude so the whole
ultimate plan is to basically control the white
house stan edgar was also kind of trying to do
that to make the company more profitable and just
make it easier for them to do what they wanted to
do but the way they're playing it on the show it
isn't so much about making money it's more about
just actual power then like i said the ending
with ryan is just meant to tease him going full
bright burn being poisoned by all of homelanders
bad teachings taking all the wrong meanings from
all these things that are happening to them like
no you're not supposed to kill people in public
don't use your powers that way and all this stuff
with the people eating up everything homelander
does it's just meant to be more culture war easter
eggs for stuff that's happening in real life like
no matter what you do whatever you say no matter
how false it is we will just eat it all up and
believe everything that comes out of your mouth
let me know in the comments though how
evil do you think that ryan is going to get
before they try to redeem the character because i
think they do want to have a more hopeful ending
for his character like he will ultimately
see what's really going on with home later
and they'll have some sort of final showdown
in whatever the final season winds up being
i will do a separate season 4 video at some point
but if there's something really big during the
episode or a big easter egg or reference
that i didn't talk about that you spotted
just write it below in the comments i've got a
bunch of thor love and thunder post credit scene
easter egg videos that i'm working on so my season
4 boys video should post in the next couple of
days while you wait for everything everyone click
here for all my thor love and thunder videos i'll
update the link as soon as i post all those videos
and you can click here for all my videos for the
boys thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!